[Music]
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna do a show
with that puppet there
whenever i say something it's like
that damn bucket down
[Laughter]
no no okay not like that that looked bad
yeah
quick shove it into your lap
[Laughter]
what are you doing that's awful
give it to the girl all right
olympics summer olympics not even yeah
whoo
yeah
haven't started yet
there's already can you believe there's
already a controversy about the olympics
there is yeah there is a lot of
americans are upset because it was
revealed that the u.s olympic team's
outfits were made in china
yeah yet a protest to protest many
people have taken down their american
flags and mailed them back to the flag
factory in china
[Applause]
[Music]
of course that puppet was made in the
good old usa right pal
it's such a
it's such a freak show here
he's got the puppet doing this now
all right knock it off
on friday oprah winfrey interviewed mitt
romney
yeah yeah the two talked about politics
foreign policy and what it's like to
lose a million dollars in the couch
cushions
bonded over that
jewish and muslim groups in germany are
outraged about a court's ruling that
circumcision should be banned
they're very angry yeah protesters have
filled the streets and uh you do not
want to know what they're waiving
the puppet likes it okay
the puppet likes it when i work dirty
according to a new report that just came
out the average canadian is now richer
than the average american
yeah yeah this is bad news for americans
and worst news for those mexicans who
know have to tunnel all the way to
canada
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i would i would suggest giant catapult
yeah
right over us
no one would get hurt doing that i'd be
fine recently uh did you hear this
recently charlie sheen's ex brie olson
revealed that charlie sheen used to
tweet during sex
yeah so if you've ever retweeted charlie
sheen you should probably see a doctor
even the puppets turning on me burger
king
good acting
that's not the puppet turning on me
that's the puppet having indigestion
what happened here
burger king's in the news burger king
has debuted its bacon sunday
bacon sunday
yeah
yeah it comes with a whipped cream and a
note that says do not resuscitate
let me go
this is crazy the world's heaviest woman
this is true the world's heaviest woman
is trying to lose weight by having more
sex
yeah in fact she just hooked up with the
world's drunkest man
[Music]
uh and then this is big news in the
world of entertainment jennifer lopez
and steven tyler are quitting american
idol
they're leaving yeah
apparently lopez wants to focus on her
music and tyler plans to star on a
remake of the golden girls
[Music]
it's just jittering
now my puppet's just having
my puppet's off his meds right now